et cet autre rassemblement aujourd'hui
pour gueye camara le jeune homme avait
été tué dans la ville d'epinay sur seine
alors qu'il se trouvait au volant d'une
voiture la famille réclame une enquête
exhaustive alors qu'un non lieu avait
été revendue au mois d'août 2010 9
une version de mise en cause par ses
proches qui ont fait appel une décision
doit être rendue le 21 janvier prochain
avec quelques personnes présentes à ce
rassemblement
au micro de luc h avocat jean bozo ne va
vraiment dit que nous a expliqué que le
21 janvier il n'y a pas d'espoir on ira
soit un non lieu et donc il est
important de le dire que nous on n'ira
pas sur un haut lieu
c'est l'état la justice française qui a
annoncé qu'il va annoncer un non lieu
mais nous le combat camara on n'ira pas
se rendre aux lieux parce qu'on connaît
la vérité on demande la justice parce
qu'on connaît très bien la vérité et mon
petit frère gay n'avait pas à mourir ce
jour là et aujourd'hui la l'état et la
justice protège des criminels on est là
pour exprimer réaffirmé le soutien de la
municipalité de chant au travail que
mène ce collectif justice pour gagner
jeu des comédiens étaient campés sien et
on partage le sentiment d'injustice qui
exprime la famille les proches et tous
ceux qui les accompagnent de la famille
camara
donc on les a soutenus depuis le début
et on continue de réaffirmer notre
solidarité avec eux c'est pour ça qu'on
est là honorer la mémoire vous expliquer
aux gens en fait que celui qui est mort
ce n'était pas un délinquant et que en
france il ya une histoire de la police
et une histoire sur ces policiers qui
peuvent tuer en toute impunité dans nos
quartiers populaires